let's get started The Wall Street
Journal check us out Spotify strikes
podcast deal with Joe Rogan worth more
than 100 million dollars well his full
library dating back 11 years is to hit
the service at ember first and become
exclusive to Spotify after that before
the end of the year
Wow there are so many implications to
this for us for everyone else okay what
does the money mean is it a good idea
maybe not okay but I mean I'll tell you
what your game you mean yeah it's tough
man because I've you know we've I'll
keep this vague but of course we've had
people approach us saying you know hey
this podcast and you really got away
opportunity for growth yeah revenue
super chat versus upfront contract cash
and I've been through all this dealing
with you know working for big companies
and getting locked into contracts and
what it means I'll tell you what man I
was in a two-year contract with that ABC
news division company right right and it
was a golden it was it was golden
handcuffs as they call it they give you
this money and then it destroys you so
for like two years I was gone yeah like
I was making some stuff and stuff did
well but it's like I go from doing these
on the ground you know viral million you
know 5 million views overnight kim.com
on Vice yeah
then I did Ukraine 2 million Ukraine
again 2 million and then I go to a
fusion and it's like what happened that
Tim pool guy
well even we were even gonna have a show
we you and I met with the president and
yeah he was like yeah this is so cool
like you guys can do this podcast that
were actually yeah right yeah that seems
to be doing well and they missed their
chance they were like yeah ok so let's
do this so that's some pretext we'll
talk about a lot of this and I'll break
down what these contracts mean Joe is
likely not getting they're not writing
him a check for hun a million dollars
right this is the average person is
gonna hear that and be like they're
gonna think Spotify was like 100 million
here you are Joe it's a lot more
complicated and I'll explain in a second
let's read the news get the context Joe
Rogan is taking his podcast exclusively
to Spotify technologies essay and a
licensing deal worth more than a hundred
million dollars according to a person
familiar with the matter that would be
one of the largest such deals in the
rapidly growing podcast business the
comedian television host and MMA
commentator has become where the most
influential and lucrative podcast hosts
in recent years especially with his
popular
vodcast video podcast format on YouTube
Rogan 52 has so far withheld his podcast
from Spotify saying the streaming
service doesn't pay enough and he had
been generating significant revenue and
other services such as YouTube his full
library dating back 11 years is to hit
the server September 1st and become
exclusive after that before the end of
the year his video podcasts which will
also appear on Spotify will no longer be
available on YouTube yes
Spotify will host the videos I didn't
know they had video that I don't think
they do this might be a specific thing
for Joe I don't know maybe they do do
they host videos I have no I have no
idea I looked like I was I was not aware
cuz that's that's huge I thought it was
just music that's huge
Spotify has spent hundreds of millions
of dollars acquiring entire companies
including gimlet media and Bill Simmons
the Simmons of the ringer the deal with
Rogen is a multi-year licensing
agreement for an amount of time that
couldn't be learned well that's an
interesting way of phrasing that hmm it
will likely be worth more than a hundred
million dollars based on milestones and
performance metrics according to the
person familiar last year the creators
of popular true crime podcast my
favorite murder signed a two-year deal
worth at least 10 million with II W
scripts COEs stitcher unit according to
people familiar with the matter in what
was then one of the largest of its kind
launched in oh nine the Joe Rogan
experience has built an avid fan base
discussing wide-ranging topics from
neuroscience sports and health to comedy
and culture his show consistently ranked
the top of Apple podcast ranking sitting
at number two on Tuesday Rogen's many
sponsors includes 23andme Dollar Shave
Club zip recruiter Joe does the best
commercials no no because it's like it
almost makes fun of the products oh
really yeah he was doing used in one
commercial we're listening to where it
was like it was uh I got what was it for
like shaving your junk yep and he was
like he was like this thing is for like
you know shaving your junk and then
apparently a light on it he's like he's
like it comes with an LED wait you got a
light on this man anybody shaving down
there in the dark you're crazy
he's a comedian so here's a quote he
says we're gonna be working with the
same crude on the exact same show as he
announced the deal on his podcast
Tuesday the only difference will be it
will now be available on the largest
audio platform in the world he also
assured his fans the podcast will still
be available
free on both Spotify Zaid supported and
premium premium tears the deal comes
after a year in which Spotify the
largest music trimming service by
subscriptions has made heavy investments
in podcasting as it recast itself as
more than just a music service it's a
very very very smart move on the part of
Spotify totally smartest thing they
could have done that nailed it now if
you were Joe Rogan
you're already wealthy I don't know I
don't know how much he makes there
there's you know you can look up
celebrity net worth that and there's
estimates based on how much money he
makes based on CPM and the ads he does
and someone I think posted a mint made a
post argument he made like 75 K per
episode or something I don't know any I
don't know anything about his metrics or
how much money he makes the question is
first foremost it's well actually look
let's break down the 100 million dollar
deal would work so you often hear this
when someone signs a contract they'll be
alike Adam griddler signed a contract
valued at five million dollars with you
know you know I know floorball Corp and
then people instantly assume you got a
check for five million right how do you
know about that
Shh it's breaking news just kidding
what's uh for poker so if it's so if
it's so there's a multi-year deal right
yeah
divide that hundred million by the by
the multi-year deal right multi-year was
at me at least three or four
well they don't even know they could not
be learned there was someone familiar so
all this is just hearsay - it's not even
real stuff I mean I'll tell you what
that was when I first heard Joe posted
the announcement that he was gonna be
leaving YouTube and iTunes yeah I said
100 million I was like what are they
paying him a hundred million bucks
because like you have to understand the
amount of reach and promotion everything
he gets from YouTube so we can talk
about why this might be a bad idea in my
opinion I don't know what Joe knows and
I know that Joe is insanely more
successful than I am
he's also got 20 years on me yeah but I
know a lot about YouTube metrics and he
probably knows a lot more about the
podcasting business him you know he's
been doing it for a lot longer mm-hmm so
I can only defer to him and say he's
probably made the right choice knowing
how much money they're offering him do
you think YouTube sweating a little bit
right now
oh they're losing that I mean he's the
number one of the number one he is
number one podcast yet world the number
one and they were on on YouTube yeah
and I and I think about how you to mess
this up remember he used to do is show
live and then they stop doing it live so
I don't exactly know why I can surmise
it has to do with the risk of getting
your live stream polled because you said
something or someone said something you
can't control it yeah I see what just
happened
tons of people have done live streams
where all of a sudden their stream gets
just removed and it's like the stream
goes dead in the middle of a live
broadcast that's why I'm like very
careful when we're reading super chats
and stuff and we're talking it's like
they could just nuke the stream
instantly and it happens so if he does
so my assumption is it has to do with
that he can better control the show and
it shows you that YouTube is not a safe
place to run your business
not even for Joe Rogan I think for the
most part you was safe let's talk about
the money real quick so if it's a
four-year deal I'm just assuming is that
what you think I would estimate because
it's Joe to at least two years it's
tough though it's tough a lot of
companies will try and get you for three
years but Joe Rogan has the leverage
yeah so I'd imagine he might you're
right we'll go for two years we'll see
how it plays out and it's a multi-year
deal yeah it might just be two years and
so that could potentially be 50 million
in in value potential value so we got to
break all this down if Joe really does
make you know like 75 K per episode I
don't know that's true no and he does
what do you do like four episodes a week
so he's making he's making a lot of
money yeah it's really good so how much
do you have to offer him to for him to
walk away from you know YouTube for
instance yeah I already set up or not
getting the money I don't think he makes
that much on YouTube
no the commercials he does i don't you
know i don't know if i believe he makes
that much money because i don't think
you know I'll stop there I don't know if
the metrics are for top YouTube show for
top iTunes shows I do know the metrics
for one of the highest profile shows
that was you know basically leaked to me
so I'm not gonna reveal who it is but
it's a very high profile individual and
they get you know like a tenth of what
they get on YouTube and it's one of the
biggest shows on iTunes so my
understanding and that's and that's
similar for for my podcast
get substantially less podcast downloads
than I do YouTube views like
ridiculously less okay and like even for
this show we get like 20 times more
views on YouTube than we do on on pod
get on the podcast okay it's like hard
to promote so I don't so anyway if
Spotify went to Joe and they were like
you know we'll give you 10 million a
year for two years then where's that
other 80 million come from well people
understand about that number is that it
could include marketing deals it
couldn't it could include production
staff support it could include travel
bonuses it could be predicated upon
reaching certain milestones like they
mentioned so what I don't know all I can
say is the number must have been good
enough for Joe and now he's gonna leave
YouTube so there's a bunch of things
talked about this is gonna be great for
us you know there really is gonna be
it's gonna be amazing
yep so I recently went on the Joe Rogan
podcast many of you may have seen it
it's currently sitting around 5.8
million views Wow I know why it's
sitting at 5.8 million views how come it
hasn't it's not entirely about Joe it's
about the YouTube algorithm okay so I
produce content every day on multiple
channels tim pool is in the description
for all of these so YouTube knows there
is there's a phrase tim pool that people
search for and click on so when I did
the Joe Rogan podcast is a reason why my
podcast was the second biggest of April
so the Eric I think it was Eric
Weinstein was the beginning of April
okay it's got like 6.1 million views so
at the end of the month is my podcast so
Eric's got a few weeks I mean it may end
up that my podcast ends up getting more
traffic in the long run but most of his
podcasts are like one you know a million
two million views because most these
people aren't on YouTube and their names
aren't recognized by the algorithm right
so when I did the podcast with Joe every
I got hit up by a bunch people being
like dude YouTube won't stop
recommending this to me it's just like
it's there it's there it's there it's a
combination of people listen for a long
time yeah but it also has to do with the
search term Tim Poole
yeah evidenced by many of you may have
noticed 20 year old skate videos with me
popping up on YouTube and it's it's it's
hilarious but there's a there's a
YouTube channel of mine with like no
subscribers that my mom was uploading to
in 2005
and it's got skate videos of me when I
was like 14 15 years old and my name's
in it mm-hmm and I'm like how did
YouTube surface this it's because Tim
Poole was in the title yep
so following you know Rogan so the
reason I bring that up is when Joe does
a podcast I don't know what his views
are like but a large portion of
everyone's views on YouTube are driven
by free marketing from the YouTube
platform so it's it's it's true for me
I've seen what happens when a video is
suppressed and I've seen what happens
when a video is promoted and when
YouTube promotes it it's like it's like
wow how did I get seven hundred thousand
views in a day it's because YouTube
YouTube algorithm put it in front of a
bunch of new people and then YouTube
actually tells you they say this podcast
you know this this video did really
really well with people who aren't
subscribed to your channel so just
walking away from that it's a big bet it
is how mean is it a bet when you're
getting paid 100 million he's not gonna
be paid but over over even even if it's
over a set amount of time it's like the
number was good enough for him to write
walk away from it and I think it's not
really a bet and I think for him he's 52
and so he's probably thinking I don't
want to I don't want to you know act
like I know what he's thinking but at a
certain point people are like you know
been there done that I did it yeah take
the money and I'm done you know what I
mean not I'm not saying that shade to
Joe I'm saying like you know for me
right now I'm hungry I'm like we're
gonna build this company where do all
these great things
mm-hmm Joe's 52 he's got a bunch of
projects he's already become the biggest
podcast in the world right you know he's
he's sitting on top of Everest and he's
like you know you got a good deal for me
it's gonna keep me comfortable for her
for a couple years now let's do it I'd
imagine it's more than two years though
simply because walking away from YouTube
that's a huge risk right but a hundred
million dollars man but he's still gonna
be uploading his clips and be making
money off youtube still it's not like
yeah letting go of completely it's just
a lot or not the live show but the
podcast itself and he's and he's
probably still gonna be doing ads on
Spotify as well and Spotify probably
said it's guaranteed promotion no but
here's here's there's something else too
it's like one of the reasons Joe is
consistently the number one podcast in
the world is because he won't get off
the top of the mountain so when people
who have never list
Podcast before open up iTunes what does
iTunes say joe rogan check out Joe Rogan
it's right there it's the first thing
you see and you're like okay and then
you've got you know Joe he's fake he's a
comedian he's famous he's funny yeah and
I tuned said so sure why not that makes
it extremely difficult for other
podcasts to you know to climb because
people have to know about it so what
you're saying is it's our time oh it's
well it's tough for us no but so this is
gonna put that out there there's other
questions there's other questions right
I'd be willing to bet one of the reasons
maybe not a big reason why Joe was like
we're gonna take the show off YouTube is
YouTube's not a safe place to run a
business so the other day I did a video
about lockdown yeah people were flooding
the beaches of Virginia defying the
orders and I post the video 10 a.m. like
normal yeah no views like it's getting
like 2 or 3 percent of the views it
normally gets okay
and I'm significantly Keolis and I'm
like is this live I look at my channel
my channel is normal yeah and I'm like I
guess the videos not getting viewed
nobody could see the video so I pulled
up incognito I looked at my channel
video wasn't there and so at first I was
thinking like men something huge must
have happened that people aren't on
YouTube right now
there was a Donald Trump interview and
I'm like maybe everybody just watch on
the Trump interview and so no one's
watching my content and then so when I
checked sure enough YouTube shadow
banned the video you couldn't see it how
do you know that for a fact because if
you log into incognito and go to my
channel the video is not there when you
when I log in I see the video that's a
Shadow Man
okay to me it looks normal to everyone
else there's nothing okay and then I
tweeted about it and a bunch of people
confirmed of screenshots the video
didn't appear for them yeah I saw your
tweets so all of these people were like
I thought Tim wasn't gonna upload any
videos this morning he must have been
sick Oh YouTube just suppressed it the
only reason that video ended up getting
views like it normally would get is
because I ask people like don't let them
do this share this video YouTube's
trying to shadow ban this I even say in
the video I'm like they're probably
gonna ban this because I'm straight-up
saying like people are defying lockdown
the people have spoken
yeah
and even this video now is at risk
because YouTube's gonna be like we
started talking about it again we side
with the lockdown no matter what even if
it's illegal I mean but look at what
YouTube has been doing they've been
kicking people out basically of the the
partnership program so they can't get
paid anymore all these the people that
you know friends Luke Ariel yep Luca
Ariel yeah exactly and I'm sure many
more la look look at what Joe talks
about you know he's he's kind of far out
there and in his different subjects that
he talks about and people he brings on
there so it wouldn't surprise me if Joe
was kind of was like there's only a
matter of time before YouTube ban he - I
want out anyway
and Spotify probably probably the spot
of he probably said to Spotify we're
gonna get real crazy with it yeah but if
I was like we don't care do your thing
we want to win yeah
so YouTube got comfortable yep they're
comfortable you can either sweatin if
you swear you lose mine mmm-hmm and so
it's like what is YouTube a kids network
you can swear on TV I'm watching that
that that new Rick and that Rick and
Morty it's called solar opposites okay
by Justin roiland it's a Fox show on
Hulu all right they stayed oh they don't
stop swear it's like sailors yeah of
course like well they swear a lot it's
not that but I don't want to exaggerate
okay they do swear a lot and so I'm like
why is it that Hulu doesn't care yeah
they run advertisers they do
subscriptions YouTube oh we can't can't
do it no swearing so we're on a platform
that is terrified of these weirdo people
who identify as deer on the internet and
are going like that's what YouTube is
scared of and so they're gonna ban us
yet I'm not surprised Joe's like I'm out
yeah what was it uh Joe routinely talks
about the trans athlete issue because
he's like really against you know
biological males that's been a bull man
it's like ban a bull of a DS against
biological males competing against bio
school FINA oh right that I finish it I
think people understand other people
that knew the context of what uh but for
those who don't right right right
so Joe you know has taught us a lot
there are biological males you know
transition they still have certain
advantages you know they compete against
biological females that is a bana Boleyn
Stu bring up
like in the way here am i agree with
them right so we're at risk yeah I've
talked to people at Google and
straight-up said tell me right now
because I refuse to start a business on
a platform that is this unsafe yeah and
they're like no no no trust that stress
it's it's okay it's okay you're gonna be
okay and I'm like then why did you ban
these people well we can't talk about
that
and I'm like that why should i why
should I believe I won't be banned at
some point as well and then they shadow
ban my video I'm like yeah I know it's
coming so you know what yeah maybe if
spot if I came to me and they were like
we want you to ditch all these platforms
okay they do videos I looked it up they
do video really I want all the
information Lydia I got nothing yeah
I'll start putting stuff on look into it
yeah yeah it's not safe man and you got
to think about like luke rudkowski right
okay Luke's been doing YouTube for over
a decade yep like 13 14 years early on
for those aren't familiar his YouTube
channel as we are changed we're probably
already in trouble for saying his name
in mention his channel early on he was
he was like peripherally involved with
like Alex Jones and like if our stuff
and a lot of conspiracy theory stuff and
then early on isn't he always though
kind of on that no yeah I guess I
haven't seen a little bit yeah there's a
little bit that he does so it's in there
but it's it's it's not nearly the same
it's like it's it's at this point you
know he's talking about coronavirus in a
very mainstream way and people are
yelling at him for it so he's a very
like I don't know it's it's it's fairly
okay there's some videos where I'm like
dude what you do it but for the but it's
like 99% of the stuff is fine they don't
care though it's his brand and so early
on he had this involvement they came and
they got rid of him and I think it's
because of some of the people get
interviewed but think about this like
let's say you you know you're you're a
young dumb kid and you make a bunch of
dumb videos so you build your channel up
over 10 years playing by the rules
everything's legit 13 years later you
got you know 700 K sobs it's your job
it's your living you've dedicated having
this platform always obeying the rules
over time you said the rule
changed I will adhere to the rules then
they say you know what your past your
brand is a negative is a negative impact
on our business
so we're purging you out right overnight
your livelihood your career things gone
where'd you go how do you make your
money just pull the rug out from under
you it would be like I always explain it
like imagine you open an ice cream shop
in like you know city center or whatever
town you live in
okay and your business is running for
years and you're making a living and
you're like this is my job and then one
day they literally come and pick up your
business and just put it 40 miles
outside the city like you can still sell
ice cream you know mm-hmm over there
where no one is and all of a sudden now
you're that's it you know your life is
over
so in the real world you can't do stuff
like that but it's the it's like the
biggest fear I guess but for me I guess
what works is that I'm kinda like a
hippie in a sense where it's if they
banned me I'd be like whatever I'm
getting the van I go skate I'm out done
you have everybody just save money and
then dip out but I guess we'll see how
this plays out because the interesting
thing about Jo Jo Pisan is that there
are a lot of people like like I know
when I can see it in my metrics when
other people are doing well or have some
calms l mm-hmm a lot of youtubers don't
get this they'll be like oh so my views
are down YouTube's oppressing me and
it's also like do you know market
competition works so if you put up a
video at the same time is joe rogan
guess what's gonna happen you're not
getting a whole lot of views right
because people are gonna go watch Joe
Rogan if Joe leaves the platform that's
one of two million views in a day or so
that he normally gets that's true
they're gonna be looking for but it's
not just that his videos are 2 or 3
hours long yeah they are that means a
million people now trying to fill 3
hours of content many of them were here
for you everyone who you really are here
we're here for you
many of them are gonna go to Spotify for
sure I don't think all of them well I'm
sure yeah
oh like like I was mentioning I'm sure a
lot of them already have Spotify it's
not you know it's not gonna be like all
right forget YouTube Spotify now you
know Spotify has been around for a long
time there's a there's a decent amount
of people on YouTube that watch because
they're on YouTube right the same is
true for Spotify or iTunes probably so I
can see it you know we can actually see
an IRL podcast you know sometimes we'll
have a massive spike in ly
viewers because of the subject matter
sure we know who are who the core people
are who are always here always hanging
out yeah so you love you guys by the way
yes talking to you yeah our core group
YouTube awesome YouTube gives you a huge
advantage free marketing hmm so long as
it fits you know what YouTube's machine
is looking for yeah if you if you made a
podcast right now put on Spotify you're
not gonna get any any downloads probably
not you make a video you put it on
YouTube you might get a million views
overnight if the algorithm says hey this
is you know what people like yeah so I
guess for some you know from my
perspective if I was now you know how
long as you live in years into the game
into the podcasting game 11 years he's
the biggest he's the best and someone
came around and said he was a contract
here's a bunch of money make sense you'd
be like yeah I'm comfortable I got my
you know I got my warehouse I got might
my friends I got my you know archery
thing or whatever his warehouse is
amazing he's got what he wants you know
yeah maybe now it's time to just get
security or something yeah I mean yeah
YouTube's gotta be sweating because they
already purged a bunch of people now you
even said the other day it's like the
algorithm seems like it's kind of back
into its normal flow you know they were
pushing mainstream media now it's back
to normal and now Joe's it a little bit
more Channel it's noticeably differently
yeah though and then now Joe leaves now
imagine if like a bunch of other heavy
podcast users get laid by Spotify you
know and then all of a sudden YouTube's
like that's millions and millions of
people that are not on our site anymore
they're yeah they got to be sweating yep
I mean dude if Spotify is hosting videos
yeah um I'm gonna check it out
yeah Spotify is legit so I'm already on
Spotify for the audio version but a
video version yeah why why not
but we'll we'll see I think one of the
one of the bigger issues too is Joe
might actually end up losing substantial
amount of his influence because he's the
biggest putt he's the biggest show on
YouTube he's the biggest show on iTunes
biggest podcast in the world will he
still be when he's on Spotify perhaps
perhaps it's hard to say TARDIS no
people go listen to Joe Rogan they like
his attitude they're like his jokes they
that's what Spotify is hoping for yeah
and so the big rest
when you sign deals like this it's
always you know why they're hiring you
right because they don't get traffic
they need traffic which means they need
to bring on talent mm-hmm so I'm sure
Joe understands all of this stuff but
there you know and maybe he doesn't
really care to have the influence he
does because he always mentions like you
know he passively mentions I might vote
for Bernie and then Bernie turns into an
endorsement yeah I can't imagine that's
fun
it's like do you not even I was just
like I might vote for the guy and all
sudden everyone's yelling at you
insulting you yeah so maybe it would be
nice to Latino to not be front center
all the time but when I look at my
metrics and I don't I don't single out
any podcast platform I don't say hey go
to this platform hey go to this platform
iTunes is 55% Spotify is like 20 so if
you open the iTunes app and you see
Joe's face every time no that gives him
a massive amount of influence over the
entire you know let's see Michael
modifies making moves that not only did
they acquire Joe they acquired a bunch
of other things over the past year like
I can't think of him off hand but you
read them in the article so it seems
like they're making moves let me tell
you story oh thank you sorry do tell
when I got hired by fusion mm-hmm they
hired a bunch of they made a bunch of
grabs from various news organizations
high-profile individuals in media and we
were called The Expendables of
journalism you know the movie
Expendables yeah like all the stars yes
everybody got paid an absurd amount of
money the contracts were we're
ridiculous okay
ridiculous one dude got paid half a
million dollars ding yeah that got
leaked like right off the bat does make
a game a half a million dollars a year
per year this contract was probably
valued at you know like 1.5 two million
dollars yep Mike I think my contract was
actually and is there's another thing
about how would it means like a hundred
million dollar deal my contract with
them I would be willing to bet as the
moat was that was the most expensive
contract for them in terms of expendable
hires but it was because I'd
requirements so you know while I don't
know if I should actually say the number
but it was in the millions well we don't
we don't need to even talk about that
but but it didn't work with them they
acquired all these Expendables didn't
work right so this modifies picking them
all up your system might not work or
yeah am I go down in flames
okay so think about it now Spotify is
solid though and it feels like they've
they've kind of been on a good
trajectory their whole life so yeah the
difference is Fusion was a bunch of
clueless people who flushed money down
the toilet and they could spend a ton of
money and it would work right isn't
Spotify a Swedish company doesn't people
have habits people have iPhones you get
Spotify on your iPhone I guess okay what
people have habits and it's also true
and their habit is gonna be like pop up
in the iTunes and so spot so - yeah I
think I think Joe is well aware that you
know he's gonna try and be pulling all
of his users you know the audience from
one platform to another okay but he's
also he's more than just a podcaster
he's Joe Rogan true he's one of the most
famous coming comedians in the world
right exactly people know his name and
so maybe that's why he's like whatever
yeah for me you know I look at how many
downloads I get on on the podcast and
it's nothing at what it's it's it's one
two hundredth of what I got on YouTube
okay so that's like it's serious if
YouTube cuts me off I'm done I'm out I'm
gonna bother him later I don't believe
you oh you're wrong Dom done I'm wrong
that I don't believe you right yeah I am
I am assuring you uh that's funny if
YouTube came and we're like we are
getting rid of all of your channels I'd
be like I'm gonna go do private
consulting or something okay well
actually we have scanners so we'd
probably I probably did doing some with
that aha and just Hiromi he wouldn't
just quit no I mean quit this political
commentary you see making videos and
stuff mm-hmm and I'd go to like driving
around the van and filming and just
doing Verte adventures you like today
we're gonna check out there's a story I
want to do for a long time with my
friend citizen sloth patrol there are
people in Central America that just
drive down looking for sloths trying to
cross the street and cook them up and
then put them on the other side because
they get run over
yeah and Turtles yeah because Turtles
trying to cross the road yeah so the
sloth patrols like a really fun thing a
big fun to go down in the jungle and
stuff and that stuff I'd probably aren't
doing if I got if I got the X bug huh I
guess well I guess we'll see how this
plays out I got to be honest bro
two things have happened that have made
me worried but very happy
the first is when YouTube announced that
they were doing this this Coppa thing
okay where I was like Children's
Protection Act or something like that
children's online you know Privacy
Protection Act and what they said was
we're gonna disable premium ads like
targeted ads for all children's channels
and disabled comments on all channels
for children and it was scary for a lot
of people because they were like what
does YouTube consider content for
children like most things yeah so if you
if you did do many things like if you're
a gamer your kids channel that means
they were like they were threatening you
people were worried they'll get their
comments disabled and so people started
doing where they were like I'll just
cuss in the video so it's not for kids
right what did Logan Paul do was it
Logan Paul where that Jake Paul you
brought on some porn stars yeah yeah
because he's like not for kids anymore
don't you know don't don't don't don't
ban me here the people don't understand
though
for channels like mine that meant a
windfall of cash money was gonna go
skyrocketing all of these channels that
could no longer support these
advertisements okay the advertisers
weren't gonna stop advertising they just
had no what advertise anymore which
meant adult content like us and like my
channel yeah that's we pick it up and so
and reminisce what's going up so at
first it's like this scared a lot of
people and I was like listen if you're a
youtuber who makes cultural and
political content you are going to see a
major increase in your in your revenues
because they're it's it's like they're
basically taking it away from all these
other channels and giving it to culture
and politics empowering people like you
know us for better or for worse the
other thing is Joe Rogan leaving at that
second thing yeah him leaving is like oh
man is YouTube off I think the biggest
Joe's leaving doesn't care anymore
what's how is you to be able to maintain
this are they are they they're banning
people I mean it could be the beginning
of the end man the walls are closing in
however there isn't it there's an a big
positive all Hill Slava's clips up yeah
they might get more views but with his
big show Monday through was a Monday
through Thursday every day at noon I
think you upload if that's gone that
means all those millions of people
plus for three hours looking for content
I got political cons are writing your
baby over to my shop and we got we got
whatever we want to talk about sonar shy
imagine this way yeah imagine it imagine
that you're like downtown and there's
two ice cream shops and one is the
biggest ice cream shop everybody loves
it and they announce we're moving we're
on a different city would be like yes
yeah now I'm the only ice cream shop in
town not that I think we in any way
compete with Rogan you know but we'll
get we'll get a little trickle from from
the Rogan viewers you know who aren't
watching on YouTube anymore
I guess CI plays out thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you